[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dear Europeans for many of us the start
of a new year marks a time for
reflection and looking to the Future to
appreciate all our many achievements and
to consider the occasional failures too
to reflect upon the adeptness of our way
of doing things and looking forward to
how we can do things differently and
better in the next year
2022 has been a difficult year for
Europe
we were tasked to deal with the
Tailwinds of the pandemic a perfect
storm of climate change inflation
spiking and energy supplies dwindling
all this against the backdrop of War on
our continent with the brutal invasion
of Ukraine and political uncertainty
that risks driving more and more people
to the comfort of the fringes the fact
is that no one country has the ability
to tackle all these questions alone
but together we have not only been able
to address seemingly insurmountable
challenges but we have also been able to
do so quickly and effectively
in 2023 we must continue on this path of
determination and unity I know that
despite all of this the storm continues
to rage on
families are still struggling to make
ends meet
young people are still worrying about
their present and their future and brave
ukrainians are still risking their lives
on the battlefield for our freedom
but if history and this year especially
has shown us anything it is that the
European Union comes out of crises
stronger and more united and so I'm
convinced that together we can do it in
the coming year we will need to deliver
we need to deliver on Europe's
competitiveness this means a return to
growth bringing our bills under control
pushing back against inflation and
making sure the green and digital
transitions continue in earnest it means
ensuring that our economy our
environment and our security are seen as
equally essential
and in 2023 we need to double down on
protecting our values Freedom democracy
Justice equality solidarity and the rule
of law these are what underpin our open
societies and our open markets without
them we have nothing
most importantly we will continue to
stand with Ukraine for a peace with
Liberty peace with dignity and peace
with security
and so may the upcoming year continue to
show the power of Europe to bring about
progress to help bring about positive
change to transform in ways that will
enable us to better address future
problems and most importantly to remind
us all that as Europeans there will
always always remain so much more that
unites us rather than divide us I wish
you all a Happy New Year